today on the matt wall show the media
scrambles to change the narrative after
the mass killer in boulder yesterday
turns out to be an arab man who killed
white people
uh they weren't expecting that and
that's not what they wanted so they had
to change the narrative we'll talk about
what the new narrative is for them also
five headlines including
the u.s senator who announced her
intentions to only vote for certain for
to confirm nominees of a certain race
isn't that extremely racist isn't that
the kind of racism that sugar you
expelled from the senate
and also a man finds shrimp tales in his
box of cinnamon toast crunch what's the
lesson we can learn from that story
there is a lesson i'll tell you what it
is finally in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the claim made by a
democratic senator and many others
that buying a gun is easier than voting
is that true all of that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
when the horrific news first broke about
the mass shooting in boulder colorado
yesterday which left 10 people at a king
super's grocery store dead
the media settled on the narrative
before the victim's
bodies had even been put into body bags
this this was another bloody rampage
carried out by a racist white male
now i say another because the shooting
last week in atlanta
which left eight victims dead has not
been officially categorized as
categorized as a race-based hate crime
by law enforcement but that hasn't
stopped the media and the democrat party
as we discussed
from insisting that it could be nothing
but a race-based hate crime
they arrived at that conclusion in spite
of the fact that the shooter himself
said his motive was sexual rage not
racial animus
now in the case of boulder they arrived
at a similar conclusion
in spite of the fact that we had at that
point absolutely
no information about the shooter or his
motives at all
and they had already determined that it
must be a white guy
caleb hall has compiled a thread of
leftists you can go look at his account
on twitter it's worth looking at
a thread of leftists in media and
politics who declared
the boulder shooter was a white male
many many many dozens
said this mina harris who's a lawyer and
also a niece to camilla harris
went so far as to say that white men
are the greatest terrorist threat to our
country
many prominent members of the left
echoed this sentiment
and then of course the narrative
collapsed authorities after taking a
suspiciously long time to tell us the
name of the killer
announced that he is a 21 year old
immigrant
from syria now some on the left
continued to cling on to the violent
white male
talking point announcing that syrians
now
basically count as white apparently
famous race baiter tariq nasheed
explained that um
syrians are quote legally politically
and socially white
this along with being abject nonsense is
especially ironic given the fact that
these same people
are quick to remind us and recently have
been especially quick to remind us
that jesus was not white well which is
it
are middle eastern men white or not
i suppose the answer is is that they're
brown when they do good things such as
heal the sick and redeem mankind
and white when they do bad things such
as murder lots of people
and this is critical race theory in a
nutshell of course
the leftists who are willing to
acknowledge um who were willing to
acknowledge they were wrong in their
initial statements about the shooter's
race
mostly excuse themselves on the basis
that that white men
commit the majority of mass shootings
tay anderson who describes himself in
his bio as a community organizer and
denver school board director
no surprise there justified his own
false assumptions
along those lines writing quote
yesterday i assumed that the shooter
involved was a white male
i was wrong over the last decade a
majority of these horrendous acts have
been white men
but i still refuse to give this murder
notoriety our attention must be on the
victims and the boulder community
how magnanimous how magnanimous and
generous of him to say that
the attention should be on the victims
he decided that after he found out who
the killer was
then he decided you know what we should
talk about the victims instead
now by the way this isn't even
necessarily true what he just said about
white males committing the majority of
mass shootings the term mass shooting is
hopelessly vague and intentionally so
it's generally defined according to the
political needs of whoever
is using the term in their mass shooting
database mother jones
defines mass shootings as
quote indiscriminate rampages in public
places resulting in four or more victims
killed
now look at all the qualifiers on that
why does have to be indiscriminate and
what do we mean by indiscriminate
and why only in a public place and why
four victims and not five or two or
three
why do they all have to die in order for
it to count as a mass shooting if
somebody goes in sprays bullets and hits
15 people and only kills two that's not
a mass shooting
well apparently not not by this
definition so these are all arbitrary
guidelines and according to
to those arbitrary guidelines indeed
white men
are most often the culprits of that kind
of mass shooting
though even by those highly selective
and random standards white men
don't commit more than their
representative share of mass shootings
when you look at their overall
the overall population percentages and
so forth but if we define mass shootings
simply as a shooting where more than one
person is shot
the picture changes dramatically and if
we do the most reasonable and worthwhile
thing
and focus on all homicides rather than
giving undue
emphasis to one particular and uncommon
form of homicide
we'll find that the majority of those
crimes are committed not by white men
but by black men
would it be okay then for me to make the
blanket assumption that
every homicide is done by black men
until i'm given specific
information to the contrary no
you know if there was just any story
about someone being murdered
someone's murdered when a liquor store
was robbed
if i were to tweet out and say must be a
black guy
i'd be call race called racist for that
yeah this is exactly what the left did
in this case
and then justified it said yeah i made a
racial assumption
of course i'll be told that that such
assumptions in my case are racist
even though the people calling racial
assumptions based on statistical
generalities racist
in that case are the same ones who make
those kinds of assumptions and justify
them
when it comes to mass shootings or quote
unquote mass shootings
now this is how the double standard
works it's also why
the race of the victims in yesterday's
shootings
has not been judged relevant by the
media or our political leaders
after the atlanta shooting there were
marches to
quote stop anti-asian hate
i'm not really sure how a march is going
to i don't know exactly
what a march against hate is supposed to
accomplish but we had those
there were demands for hate crime
charges to be filed
media editorials about the whiteness
pandemic
representative judy chu who played this
clip couple days ago of california said
on abc news that she knows in her heart
and in her mind that the shooting was a
hate crime
and she knows that simply because a
majority of the victims were asian
and the shooter was white by that
standard
if we were allowed to apply the same
standard it must be concluded that
yesterday's terrible crime was an
anti-white hate crime
in that case all 10 victims were white
and the perpetrator despite desperate
claims of the contrary
was a non-white arab man why should we
not be calling for hate crime charges
here why should we
not be organizing stop anti-white hate
rallies
it's true that that we don't know the
killer's motive at this point but
when has that ever stopped the
race-baiters
it's only stopped him in this case after
gearing up to make this shooting into
yet another story about race
they shamelessly pivoted as soon as they
heard the name of the killer and now
they wish to discuss issues like mental
health
and gun violence instead it was
considered insensitive and even racist
to blame mental illness for the atlanta
shooting
because that would be to let the killer
off the hook it would be to distract
from the
the matter of his alleged racism we were
told
you'll notice that that last week cnn
featured no segments like the discussion
this morning
where host allison camerata questioned
why the gun shop owner who sold the
boulder shooter his weapon
didn't first conduct a psychological
examination that was her question
let's listen to that why in case in
terms of making
change since it seems intractable
at the national level why don't we go to
gun shop owners
and say do you think that this 21 year
old who comes in and wants an ar-15
style weapon
do you think that he looks like he's
going hunting
with this weapon did you ask him um by
the way do you ever think that people
are chasing you
do you ever hear voices saying that
people are coming for you do they ever
ask
questions like that because this guy it
sounds like according to his family
would have answered yes the
the short answer is in our society we
don't ask those questions
we don't demand of gun shops that they
ask those questions
uh we have a a a
perspective in america that there is a
right to buy a weapon
absent some compelling and obvious
circumstances
and uh gun shops don't ask those
questions and it's
it's very very painful now sane
people can identify many legal and
logistical problems with such a plan
it's also interesting that the left
demands greater scrutiny and oversight
for an adult who wants to buy a gun than
a child who wants to get a sex change
but this is all part of the twisted
story of modern leftism
double standards contradictions they
present themselves in rapid succession
and we're supposed to just go along with
the program don't comment on it
cooperate with the ever-shifting
narrative never
stop to question any of it
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
you know sometimes i think it's it's
important to be able to unplug from the
news and politics not sometimes we
should be doing that
uh a lot we should spend a lot more time
unplugged from it than we do plugged
into it
even the case for me and that's where i
think my bookie can really help
march is here and madness has officially
begun it's time for you to shoot your
shot and score big on the non-stop
action
with my bookie select the winners from
63 tournament games
in the my bookie bracket contest for a
chance at ten thousand dollars in cash
prizes
and it's only a dollar for for entry
doesn't matter
whether you're filling out multiple
brackets betting the national
championship winner or simply looking
for players and game props
my bookies got you covered sign up today
at mybookie.ag and use promo code walls
to secure
a deposit bonus of up to a thousand
dollars don't miss out on that
that's promo code walsh to claim your
deposit bonus college ball
nba nhl no matter the sport no matter
the the minute my bookie puts the action
in your hands with in-game live betting
it's a lot more fun when you've got the
bet with my bookie
and with choices from thousands of lines
and odds you can't you can turn any game
day into payday
and just like i said make it a lot more
fun on top of that so bet anything
anytime anywhere
with my booking yeah i uh by the way i
have i have uh
i've gotten your messages or emails i've
i've got many many people have sent me
the stories
um including the daily wire
yesterday about how we're now told that
beards make
face masks less effective so i've gotten
all those
and my you know i don't know if people
sending me this they're they're trying
to convince me to shave the beard
just more anti-beard bigotry i'm sure
that's what it is but i think
first of all yes i already knew that of
course i i every time i put the face
mask
on i know that look this is not it's not
doing much because i got all the beard
here and
i'm sure the virus can still navigate
its way up
um because i'm not exactly getting an
airtight seal here so i'm i'm
plenty aware of that this is why i've
said all along or at least thought all
along
that i should get a medical exemption
from wearing a mask
because i'm bearded that's that's the
way i look at it
now let's go number one here so we we uh
as mentioned of course the left is
making
this particular shooting a story about
gun control
and you did hear you heard a little bit
of that last week
but not as much and the reason is that
they wanted to focus on the racial
aspect they wanted that to be the main
story
and they also didn't want to talk about
mental illness
last week because that would be they
would think as
as i said you know that that would seem
to if if the guy's crazy
then it's not really a matter of racism
or if he is raised if you're crazy and
racist then you can't really be blamed
for your racism because you're crazy
they really want to talk about it then
they want to talk about this uh
this week so joe biden
announced yesterday um what he wants to
do
about gun control and here's here's his
plan let's listen this is the one thing
i do know enough to say on in terms of
what's happened there
while we're still waiting for more
information regarding the shooter his
motive
the weapons he used the guns the
magazines the weapons the modifications
that apparently have taken place
to those weapons that are involved here
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives
in the future and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
in this country once again i got that
done when i was a senator
it passed it was law for the longest
time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
we can close the loopholes on our
background check system
including the charleston loophole that's
one of the best tools we have right
now to prevent gun violence
yeah a lot of problems there the first
one is i don't know what an assault
weapon is
yeah i'm not sure i'm not that's still
no one is quite made clear what you mean
by
assault weapon what is that supposed to
mean
that's why in fact when when you hear
the statements when you hear a statement
that um
a there was a mass shooting committed
with an assault weapon
that that doesn't really tell you
anything
that tells you almost nothing about what
actually happened in the shooting what
kind of weapon was used
how many people died motive
there's no it really no there's a basic
an all-button meaningless statement to
say that because those two terms
can mean anything and
it here's what assault weapon means
it means a weapon is an assault weapon
if it is a weapon that democrats right
now are trying to ban
why are they trying to ban it because
it's an assault weapon
why are they calling an assault weapon
because they want to ban it and so we go
around around in circles like that
in reality though that that term has no
has no objective meaning whatsoever
and that's a real problem now in more
political news senator duckworth
senator tammy duckworth
i really think one of the most vile
and repulsive people in the senate she's
just a she's a really bad person
uh and a and a terrible incompetent goon
and she should be expelled from the
senate from for
i think probably several reasons but
here's number one that's the only reason
i need to give you
this is a report this is from chad uh
pergram is a fox news reporter
he says reporting from the pool
democratic
illinois senator duckworth um talking
about the effort to get more diverse
nominees
out of joe biden she says i'm a no vote
on the floor on
all non-diversity nominees you know
this is her talking again you know i
will vote for racial minorities and i
will vote for lgbtq
but anybody else i'm not voting for
okay that's what we call that that's
called racism of course
now when you say i want diverse
nominees that's another way of saying i
don't want white people
that's all she's saying i don't want
straight white people that's why i don't
want
of course in in reality to just to call
someone
oh that's not a diverse person i want a
diverse
person white person what does that mean
how can a person be diverse in and of
themselves
again a word with no meaning it just
means whatever they wanted to mean in
the given moment and in this case it's
it's it is a
very thinly veiled way of saying i don't
want to vote for white people
i'm a non-white person i don't like
white people and i don't want to vote
for them
flat-out racism and she's free to be a
racist um
bigoted scumbag all she wants to be
but that should not be acceptable in the
senate she should be expelled from the
senate for that
and the republicans if they had any
backbone they'd be calling for that
right now
we need to have hearings we need to do
whatever we can she needs to be gone
we cannot have people in the senate who
are going to stand up and announce ahead
of time
that they're racist against a certain
race and they're not going to approve of
anybody who is that race
obviously we can't and it goes without
saying that if this was a white
republican saying you know i'm not
interested in any nominee who isn't
white
i want to stick with my own people and
uh if they're not white i'm not
interested in them
and if they're not straight i don't want
any gay nominees so if they're not a
white straight person i don't want them
if a republican were to say that and
course you can't you can't imagine a
politician saying that they never would
but it would be it would be it
the nuclear you cannot even conceive of
the nuclear
meltdown that would happen on the part
of the media
and uh the democrat party and they would
not stop until that person was gone
should be the same damn thing here it is
just as bigoted and racist and
disgusting
but meanwhile this same person she's
she's concerned about
um racial hatred while she exhibits that
hatred and encourages it
and wants to vote based on it she's
she's concerned about it too she wants
to she wants to
make sure that we get rid of a uh of of
racial hatred
specifically anti-asian hatred so here
she is talking about the effort to um
get an anti-asian hate crime bill
passed here she is let's listen the
president on friday endorsed
uh a bill i know you are a co-sponsor of
uh
called the covet 19 hate crimes act
um all the co-sponsors are democrats do
you have any pledges from
republicans to sign on we don't at this
time and it's astonishing to me
i mean the house passed a bill that
actually um conde was a resolution
against hate crimes against asian
americans tied to covet
and you know we had actually republicans
who voted against it and mitch mcconnell
at the time because republicans were in
charge wouldn't even let us vote on it
in the senate
i mean how where can you be that you
would not be willing to vote on a bill
that would condemn violence against any
group of americans
well she's she's scandalized how could
anyone exhibit that kind of bigotry
except for me of course well only she's
allowed to be a bigot
i wish she would just come out and say
that i'd almost respect it i'd respect
the honesty at least if she came out and
said listen
i'm i am a flaming bigot but but no one
else is allowed to i i'm allowed to be
but nobody else can
yeah let's let's get a a a hate crime an
anti-asian
coveted hate crime bill what
so okay so so it's already illegal to
commit a hate crime against an asian
person
in fact it's illegal two times over
if you were to assault an asian person
it's illegal because it's assault
and then it's a federal hate crime
because it's race-based
so it's illegal twice and now they want
to make it illegal three times
let's add another law on top of it let's
make it illegal three times over and if
that's not enough let's make it let's
pass another bill
let's just keep passing bills
until any time someone does that they've
committed 20 crimes instead of one
you know what if you we could get rid of
all of this nonsense
because you really only need to make an
act illegal once
it only has to be illegal once but if
you're if you
if you're saying to yourself oh well
there's not enough uh it's still not
dissuading people
you know there's people are still doing
it uh this is this is a more serious
crime okay well then
if you want to make the penalties
harsher i'm all about that not just for
anti-asian assault but if you want to
make the penalty
harsher for assault for example
someone who goes up and assaults a
random innocent um
pedestrian walking down the street or
whatever it is and we've seen we see
cases like that all over the place
asians being targeted white people being
targeted black people
um if you if you're saying
that those crimes are not um
treated harshly enough by the justice
system i agree with you
i think the person that does something
like that should go to jail for put them
in jail for 30 years for all i care
there was that case in baltimore which
we we haven't heard anything about i
don't know if there's been any update on
it but there was a case of the um
we had the video that we played months
ago of white guy walking down the street
uh someone runs up black guy runs up
behind him with a brick and bashes him
over the head runs away
we have we heard almost nothing about
that when it happened we've heard no
update on that case
but if they found that guy or if they do
find him
how much jail time is he going to get
i mean a couple of years at most
i'd say put that guy put that scumbag in
jail for 50 years put him in jail for
the rest of his life
i mean that is someone we don't need in
society like we don't need you
if you're doing something like that we
don't need you you're gone
one strike you're out i never want to
see you outside of a prison cell
ever again i'm fine with that
whoever the victim is white black asian
doesn't matter
um but that's not what they want though
you know because and they don't care
about the white guy getting back with a
break they don't think they give a damn
about that
this is all just political posturing
because when it comes down to it these
people
this is not the tough on crime party
if they were i'd be right along with
them say you want to get tough on crime
you want to put these
violent dirt bags in jail for a long
i'm with you let's do it
all right number two there's um an
unintentionally horrifying article in
the brown daily herald which is brown
university's new
newspaper about the um and this is about
their new online system
for reporting sexual harassment and
assault online
anonymous what could go wrong the
article says the title ix office
introduced a new method of reporting
incidents of sexual harassment sexual
violence or gender-based discrimination
on its website
the online sexual violence and gender
harassment incident reporting form
aims to provide an easy mechanism to
report incidents
this according to the title ix program
officer renee davis
the form allows students to report
descriptions of incidents concerns that
involved persons such as
alleged aggressors harmed individuals
and witnesses
as well as the desired response from the
title ix office students can also opt to
make their reports anonymous
so you can you can implicate somebody in
a crime
you can tell the school what punishment
you want for that alleged perpetrator
and you could do all this anonymously so
that the person being accused
doesn't even know who's accusing them
has no right supposed to have the right
to face your accuser in court
none of that out the window that's at
brown university
anonymous online reporting of crimes
and then and then the second part of
that is that the person accused of
course
goes into the kangaroo court the the
rape tribunal or whatever
and is uh summarily punished no evidence
i mean think about that not if you're if
you're
a man being and this is it's all going
to mostly be men accused anyway as we
know
and that's the point here but you're
being accused of something
no evidence is brought to bear
and you don't even know who's accusing
you and you get
kicked out of school labeled a rapist
for the rest of your life
yet another reason to be very careful
about sending your kids off to college
especially your sons
um let's see this is a story that gets
more and more bizarre okay
um a guy says that he found shrimp tails
in his cinnamon toast crunch
now and i was reading this story every
every sentence it gets
it gets weirder and weirder so i i guess
he had already he
he ate a bowl of cinnamon toast crunch
and then he was pouring more
because he was going to eat another ball
and the shrimp tails fell out of the box
and this guy first of all is apparently
the husband of the woman who played
topanga on boy meets world because why
not
and also his other box of cereal
evidently had
dental floss in it and there was a hole
in the
in the bag and then it was taped over
and there was dental floss in it
which really whoever did this may i feel
bad for this guy
believe me i i would be traumatized for
the rest of my life
but it's kind of brilliant in an evil
way because
if you could think of like what are the
two worst things you could find in a box
of cinnamon toast squash that's probably
it
shrimp and dental floss it's hard to
think of something worse than that
and then he contacted the company and
originally the cinnamon toast
i guess it's kellogg's i don't know i
don't want to implicate them whoever
makes cinnamon toast crunch
they um originally they said that the
shrimp tails only looked like shrimp
tails so this was a little bit of like
spilled milk situation where it can look
however you want
they said no it's not a shrimp tail it
is uh it is clumps of cinnamon that is
congealed together and take in the form
of a shrimp
which which you know if i was a cinnamon
toast crunch customer
i wouldn't feel a lot better about that
that the cinnamon can do that it
wouldn't make me feel much better
but then he says no it's really shrimp
and uh apparently now they're
backpedaling and they're trying to
figure out what it was
i mean in fairness to them this could
have been
if it's not all a hoax this could have
been something that happened in the
grocery store
that would be my first guess that
someone in the grocery store did this
i don't know but here's the lesson from
i said there's a lesson we can learn
from this and here's the lesson
this is what you get um for being an
adult
who eats cinnamon toast crunch that is a
children's cereal
like if you're over the age of say 15
you shouldn't be eating it in the first
place so yes this is me victim blaming
you get what you deserve that that
that's the lesson there
really as an adult you shouldn't be
eating cereal at all
it it's arguable whether adults should
be eating breakfast
frankly um but certainly not cinnamon
toast crunch
if you got if you're going with with
breakfast cereal if you've got to do
that as an adult you got to go bland
this is what adults do
shredded wheat raisin bran
okay that's what we eat as adults it's
penance for our sins
finally i have to do this you know i i
have no choice but to do this i don't
want to do it i have to do it
we have another video of some
middle-aged liberal woman
on tick-tock singing a song that she
made up
um this one about the stimulus package
and every time i play this stuff on the
show people get mad at me
and i want you to know i have no choice
you know i feel that it's my obligation
or at least if i
have suffered through this then i i feel
as though for your own good you should
as well
i hope that makes it better but here's
the song listen
look at this stuff isn't it neat
competent leaders getting us back on our
feet
the american rescue plan it has
almost everything
a year into this mess recovery unfolds
how many wonders can one rescue plants a
little mermaid i think right reading hit
over you'd think
really i know my disney phone no
republicans voted for this thing
it's got direct relief to american
families
it's got a path to reopen our schools
cost of child care tax credits baby
it's like they care it's a big
deal mental illness is a serious problem
don't you imagine the neighbors the
people looking out their window and
seeing this happening
go wanna go out dancing
having convos with those what are they
called again
oh yeah friends okay
turn this off turn this off turn it off
who put this on oh my gosh
and who there's someone behind the
camera who is behind who is doing
this to this poor
disturbed woman like someone in that
family i don't know if it's the husband
or a child it's probably one of the kids
you know whoever it is your mo your
mother comes to you and says
uh listen i wrote this song about the
stimulus package uh it's kind of uh
it's based on a little mermaid so i
wanted to perform it uh and then put it
online will you will you film
if you love your mother there's no way
you say yes to that
no you you go you you take her to
therapy you take her to counseling
you say mom listen i know it's been a
tough time there are people who can help
you let's get in the car let's go talk
to some people okay
it's gonna be fine we don't need to do
this
that's who i'm angry with i am angry at
the family members who allow these women
to do this
if you have a middle-aged woman in your
in in your family
this is what and she wants to to make a
tick tock video with a song she made up
under no sir maybe pretend you're
filming if she really insists
take out the phone and say okay mom go
ahead wow this is a great song yeah i'll
post this online
oh my goodness all right let's uh let's
move on to reading the youtube comments
this is from bobby backs he says i
switched from gillette to harry's
because
of their wokeness now i guess i have to
grow a beard yeah well that's that's see
that's it
gillette gillette went woke harry's went
woke all of the razor
blade companies are going woke and
that's all the more reason all the more
incentive
you grow a beard you don't have to worry
about this anymore uh another comment
says when i was three i would go to my
mom's closet and put on her high heels
because i thought they were funny
i'm glad i wasn't manipulated into
thinking that my that that's my real
identity forced to cross-dress and
eventually injected with puberty
blockers
yes i hear this all the time from from
adults
at least the reasonable ones the
rational insane ones
saying man i can't all all of the crazy
stuff that i said when i was a kid all
the
things i pretended that i was all the
claims i made when i was a child
i'm so glad my parents weren't insane
enough to take that seriously
um another comment says dude your whole
rant about trans kids is so correct kids
don't know what they mean because they
have a limited vocabulary and don't know
which words to use when they express
how they feel about things because they
don't understand their emotions yet
that's the most true statement i've ever
heard and it's honestly a statement
that should go without saying yeah it
should uh it should if you if you
understand
this is not on my part some sort of deep
insight into child psychology this is
this basic basic level insight to child
psychology that
you don't even need to be a parent to
have this insight because you were a kid
yourself at one time if you can remember
if you can remember back
to that at all you know you can remember
being a child who believed all kinds of
crazy things as a kid
um mike dutton says i'm a terrible
person
can't stop laughing at the term fat
community
yes i'm fat but that doesn't make you a
terrible person
that makes you a normal person because
the term fat community is absurd
this is one that's a another thing you
notice is how this word
talk about words that that um are are
vague and meaningless now
community is another one everything is a
community now
a fat community well what exactly is it
the only thing if you're if you're
overweight if you're obese the only
thing that you
necessarily have in common with the
other members of the obese community is
that you all
eat too much relative to the amount of
calories you burn that's how you lose
weight
now look i understand there are
conditions there are
disabilities people can have and all
that but vast majority of cases
if you're gaining weight it's not
complicated
it's not a mystery you're gaining weight
because you're eating
more than you're burning
that's it in fact i i just read it there
was a survey done
and i i i find this hard to believe that
but the survey claimed
that um a majority of americans gained
weight during the
uh during the covet lockdowns now that
part is easy to believe but then they
claim that
you know the average weight gain was
like i think it was like 20 pounds or
more than that
that seems a little bit hard to believe
but the point is people are gaining
weight that's
totally believable during the lockdowns
why are they gaining weight did everyone
develop a thyroid condition
no it's because they weren't moving
around as much
and they were eating more and you gain
weight
does that make you a part of a community
a community of of like-minded people no
just you all share the same vice and by
the way it's a vice that we all share to
some degree or another i mean we all
commit the sin of eating too much at
least sometimes
um and finally walsh is probably my
favorite daily wire commentator guy
rivaled only by knowles shame he doesn't
even have his own wikipedia page that's
true
i don't and i've complained about that
before i should probably complain about
it more
this is a serious problem in my life and
i think for for i think you would agree
on your own as well
this is how this was this some of the
persecution i suffer
that i've been giving my opinion online
for years
and i still don't want a wikipedia page
no one tell me i'm privileged okay i
don't even have a wikipedia page
we've been talking about the attack on
gun rights today and we'll have more to
say about that coming up in the daily
cancellation
which makes it a perfect time perfect
transition to tell you about my friends
over at constitutioncoach.com
they got a lot of great programs for
equipping citizens to defend liberty by
studying
and living out the constitution and i
just experienced as i've been telling
you about their constitutional defense
course
i went out to nevada at a front sight
and i took their course
and i i couldn't be happier that i did
so that i can
you know i could start to to learn i've
always supported the second amendment
i've always believed in gun ownership
but i i realize i've got to really
finally focus on
learning how to use this thing and
getting myself trained up
and that's something that we should all
be doing you can get an amazing
combination of intellectual ammunition
and live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and but
also get physical training at the
premier firearms training facility in
the nation all in the same course you've
got to see this this facility by the way
it'll it'll blow your mind you get to
join hundreds of other patriots from
across the nation for a time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people
whether you have whether you've shot
guns your whole life or you've never
touched one or you're somewhere in
between
i'm telling you these people they took
me to an entirely different
level of comfort and skill that i didn't
think was possible don't just get a gun
you got to learn how to carry with
confidence you also have to get the
training you need to defend your family
and you've got to learn about all the
rights all the
all the things that give us the rights
and the abilities to do this in the
first place so go to
constitutioncoach.com
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
it'll fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today and watch my
video there to
find out more about how you can be a
part of this
adventure and this kind of training
constitutioncoach.com
well if you haven't heard by now um but
i'm sure you have heard by now if you've
listened to this show so you know
and if you haven't been listening then
how dare you candace owens has a brand
new talk show
with us exclusively at dailywire.com the
full show is available at daily wire
for daily wire members only but candice
the podcast
is available um on apple spotify
anywhere else you get your podcast the
canvas podcast features several breakout
segments from the full length show
including interviews panel discussions
and her advice corner so you can get
that but
what i would recommend is also you want
to tune in become a daily wire member
and um watch the entire show you can do
all that now and also you can head over
to apple podcast or spotify and
subscribe today and be sure to leave a
five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know one of one of the favorite
strategies of the gun grabber is to
compare the alleged ease of purchasing a
firearm to the alleged difficulty of
performing some random other task
often you'll hear it formulated this way
they'll say in america it's easier to do
x than it is to vote we really have our
priorities screwed up
president obama was famously fond of
this particular mad lib
on more than one occasion he filled in
the blank with book claiming that it's
harder somehow to obtain a book
than to obtain a shotgun this
may be true if the book you're trying to
obtain is one that the left has already
banned or burned
but as long as you're not trying to buy
some forbidden text like dr seuss's mick
elegance pool
it's quite easy to buy books you can
even get them for free at the library
in most cases kids as young as six can
obtain a library card
check out all the books they want no
questions asked
as i said there are many versions of
this buying a gun is easier than such
and such formulation yesterday senator
alex padilla of california was one of
several democrats to put a familiar spin
on this old yarn
echoing a washington post editorial
published a few days ago he claimed
that buying a gun is easier than voting
let's listen you know for most states
the age required
to legally purchase a rifle
and the age required to cast a ballot
are both 18. however there's some
shocking disparities
in uh legal state requirements for
obtaining a weapon versus
casting a ballot in 25 states
voters must be registered and have
specific forms of
id in order to cast the ballot but those
same
states allow people to buy rifles
without permits
and require no background checks for
some sales
additionally in the majority of states
new voters are
able to obtain a rifle quicker
than they're able to cast their first
vote
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
than we do to cast a ballot priorities
are way out of whack according to this
thing i just made up we should note that
politifact has previously
fact-checked this claim and determined
that it's true
they said it's true but if you're not
convinced of the truth of a claim simply
because a website with fact in its name
says that it's true it may be necessary
to take a closer look
and you don't need to look very long or
hard to discover that
what we're dealing with here is anything
but a fact it is rather a gross and
absurd
fabrication and one that quickly
evaporates on closer inspection first
let's consider the process of voting
okay all right
if you want to vote and you're a legal
adult
the only thing standing between you and
the ballot box is the requirement that
you register ahead of time which you can
even do on the same day that you cast
the ballot in many states you can also
accomplish this task online
requires no money no additional hoops
must be jumped through
or obstacles navigated you must only
provide proof that you're a resident of
the state in which you'll be
you'll be voting and that'll be the end
of it as for voting itself you can do it
through the mail from the comfort of
your own home you can do it early you
can do it on election day
there's nothing difficult or confusing
about voting any legal adult providing
they're not
a convicted felon though even that's not
going to permanently rule you out in
most states
can vote there's quite literally nothing
standing in your way
when you want to vote it's free it's
easy the only pre
prerequisite is that you might have to
provide
minimal proof that you're voting in the
right state
voting is so easy that 155 million
people successfully completed the task
in 2020
i mean it could be said without
exaggeration that literally every single
person
who wanted to do it and was eligible to
do it
did it how can a thing be any easier
than that
what about purchasing a firearm well the
first thing that purchasing a firearm
requires is money
that alone makes obtaining a firearm
more difficult
than voting we could end our comparison
right there
one is free one is not one is a free
activity that any legal adult can engage
in
the other is an activity that requires
money end of discussion right there
but the differences extend far beyond
that there are a great many laws
governing who can buy our firearm what
kind of firearm they can buy
where they can buy it where they can
carry it what they can do with it
when and where they can do the things
they can do with it etc
it's true that it's generally easier to
purchase some guns than others
okay so the laws aren't the same for
every gun but that's the point the
prospective gun owner
must first navigate the red tape and
research the laws to figure out which
gun he can buy and how we
how he's supposed to buy it no such
process
is necessary for voting many states
require waiting periods before buying a
gun some stakes require waiting periods
for all guns
you could buy some guns online but the
guns that you do buy a line have to be
shipped to a licensed dealer
no sort of equivalent red tape exists
for voting online again
there really is not red tape at all for
voting except the most
basic and easily navigated requirements
anyone can do it if you fulfill those
really basic requirements you can do it
this is not the case for buying a gun
you can also lose your rate your right
to
to a gun much easier than you can lose
your right to vote
federal law prohibits felons from
obtaining firearms no such federal law
excludes
felons from voting um you you can even
lose your gun rights for being
dishonorably discharged from the
military
for a host of other reasons there's no
comparison here
voting is simple it's free it's easy
buying a gun is expensive and
complicated
and may even be impossible depending on
who you are and what gun you want to buy
and where you live
voting is much easier than buying a gun
much easier
but and this is where i might lose you
it shouldn't be see i wish the
democratic fable was true
i hear them say stuff like this and i
think man if only
i wish the situation reversed was
reversed i wish they were telling the
truth
gun ownership is after all a more
important and more essential right than
voting
more people should own a gun than vote
and it should be easier to do
voting is not really a human right at
all you want to know the truth it's not
a human right
it is a privilege granted to us and a
privilege that should be reserved for
those who are the most qualified to do
it
that's voting the ability to defend
yourself and your family is fundamental
it has to be fundamental
if you can't preserve your own life then
you can't do anything else certainly you
can't vote
well i mean in some cases maybe you
still can vote even if you don't
preserve your own life
um we all have the god-given right to
ensure
our own safety and that of our loved
ones but determining the political
course of the nation is something
different
it's not fundamental and it should it
should
not be opened up to any warm body or
even cold body in some cases
there ought to be tests there ought to
be requirements for voting that rule out
millions of current voters who are not
equipped to take part in the process and
have no business involving themselves in
it that's the way it should be
but that's not the way it is
so even though i i wish that this that
this
fable was true this fantasy land that
the democrats have
have uh have concocted in their heads i
i wish it
this is the one time where i wish it was
actually a reality
but it's not not even close not remotely
close
and so for that reason they of course
are all once again
canceled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vladovsky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
a terrible shooting in colorado raises
bad faith debate
a breakfast company gaslights a man who
found shrimp tails in his cereal
and a democrat senator won't vote for
white nominees check it out
on the michael knowles show
[Music]